AT A CHURCH KILLING TWO AND
INJURING THREE LAST WEEK.
THE U.S. SUPREME COURT IS
CONSIDERING ARGUMENTS ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S POLICY TO
EXCLUDE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS FROM
THE CENSUS.
IT’S A HUGE ISSUE BECAUSE THE
CENSUS DETERMINES CONGRESSIONAL
REPRESENTATION AND FUNDING
DECISIONS IN EACH STATE.
CORRESPONDENT DAVID SPUNT HAS AN
UPDATE TONIGHT.
>> THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY
11 MILLION UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
WANTS TO REMOVE ALL OF THEM FROM
THE 2020 CENSUS.
IN ONE OF HIS LAST ACTS IN
OFFICE, THE PRESIDENT HOPES TO
TAKE THE MODIFIED FINAL COUNT
AND PASS IT ON TO CONGRESS.
>> THE REAL FIGHT IS SUBSTANTIVE
HOW MUCH DISCRETION A PRESIDENT
HAS.
>> REMOVING MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
MEANS REMOVING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FROM STATES AND CITIES
TEXAS, CALIFORNIA AND NEW JERSEY
ARE.
SO STATES EXPECTED TO LOSE
FUNDING AND POTENTIALLY
CONGRESSIONAL REPRESENTATION IF
THE TRUMP TEAM WINS IN COURT.
JUSTICES FROM BOTH WINGS OF THE
COURT APPEARED SKEPTICAL OF THE
ADMINISTRATION’S ASK, ESPECIALLY
UNDER A TIGHT DEADLINE THERE ARE
31 DAYS LEFT IN THE YEAR TO
EXCLUDE THE 10.5 MILLION SEEMS A
MONUMENTAL TASK.
>> WE HAVE TO DECIDE AS A MATTER
OF LAW WHETHER THE WORD PERSONS
AS USED IN THE STATUTE AND
CONSTITUTION WHO LIVE HERE
PERMITS THE EXCLUSION OF ILLEGAL
ALIENS.
>> THIS CASE MARKS THE FIRST BIG
TEST FOR JUSTICE AMY CONEY
BARRETT AS IT RELATES TO
EXECUTIVE POWER AND HOW MUCH
POWERED MAMG WHO APPOINTED HER
TO THE BENCH CAN HARNESS.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME IN
HISTORY A PRESIDENT HAS
UNILATERALLY MOVED TO REMOVE
MILLIONS OF UNDOCUMENTED FROM
THE CENSUS.
JUSTICE BARRETT QUESTIONED THE
ADMINISTRATION’S MOVE.
>> A LOT OF THE HISTORICAL
EVIDENCE AND LONGSTANDING
PRACTICE REALLY CUTS AGAINST
YOUR POSITIONS.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS SUPPOSED TO
RECEIVE THE FINAL CENSUS NUMBERS
BY DECEMBER 31st.
BUT THAT DATE COULD SLIDE
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC.
IF IT SLIDES PAST JANUARY 20TH.
PRESIDENT BIDEN COULD WITHDRAW
THE CASE FROM THE SUPREME COURT
AND KEEP THE 11 MILLION IN THE